みなさんこれ知ってますがこれじゃない奴も見た事あると思うんですけどもこれはです
ね防犯ブザーというやつでございます
やばいこれなんかすぐヤバイんであればああうん
小さい子供とか持っておりかもしれないんですけども時間と化す動画とかね不審者とか
そういう人に追われてちょっと危険な時にですよだれも周りにいないと助けてくれる人
は誰もいないときにこれを引っ張ればデカイ音が誰ので笛を聞いた人が助けに来て
くれるというものでございます防犯ブザーあんまりでこういうのはいえて鳴らす音
ないんですよねこの防曇メジャーなんですけども俺を持ってしまったここを塗っても音
が鳴るんですよこれここね
シャーベットブーブー抜くとせず音がなっちゃうんですけどもうその後止めるのが
難しい例えば今これ抜いてあげますよ
yeah yeah
って感じでねあのー応答がめちゃくちゃ願いですよ戻すのに時間がかかるから仮に
間違えて抜いちゃってとしたらそれ直すのにすっごい大変なんですよ嬉しいんですよ
ずっと pb フィットなってるからも大迷惑なんて読めないと音が止まんないって
いう危険性も金しかないんだ立法間違えれば今日気になってしまうそういう危険なもの
なんですそれぞれ考えた今回ですねこの棒
3ブザーなんですけどこの穴を刺す以外の方法で留めれば一番良いのかなと思いまして
今回ぼく何とか作成を考えてみました
防犯ブザーをこの世紀の方法以外の方法で止める方法ちと調べていこうと思います実際
にちょっと1個ずつやっていきましょう
水って言うのはね音が2割にくいですよもうこれボタンで入れるだけでやっとしたら
もうとがなくなるかもっ
もう1個あるんだよもう1個あるんだよこういう時もあると思ってもう一個準備したよ
持っています
水に入れてもいい
もう死にそうじゃこれじゃなれば助けに来ないよーいい
以外で3月9な音を出した状態で入れてみましょうできます3て1ん
おおぉ効いてる効いてる気だよ
を効いてる効いてるだしてみません
水を聞きますねー
セミとが帰るとか凄いなまたたくさん入れてみたら
音楽たリアルも結構買ったんでしょ全部入れてみましょう
いい
dvd
死んだなで厚木校
金属でできているわけですよ金属類と書き換えるっていうのはやっぱ熱に弱いんでもう
寝しじみたら万般
ないですね会いジョブすぐ行けばつい true はんっ
uh
wh
やばいこれ立つ
強い爆発発実装大丈夫かな
左次
水とか炎とかっていうのはねすんで準備できないんで稼げてるね工具を使いましょう
ドライバーだけで遭難部分があるのであんな音とこれでもさん早く取れないとダメなん
だよね音が鳴ってから取ればです幕てすぐ止めるからも ok です時間が飾りを張っ
たら使えないですね船ディ
go eo
me
ni
あっと思った余裕じゃん子早くにこれ有効だなければありもう上げて上げて打つんで一
発でしたいやーよ
def